Hello.
Hello, everyone.
Alright.
Let me share my screen, and we will
get started.
Cool.
Awesome.
So
what we're gonna do today
is I am going
to do my damnedest
to build a custom image
for deployment to packet.
Now
if you're not familiar with what packet is,
that's fine.
We are going to quickly deploy a vanilla
server using one of the already supported distributions,
and just take a look at the flow
of how that works. And we're gonna use
the UI today rather than any sort of
automation
just to keep this relatively quick so that
we can go on to the watching me
potentially feel miserably to build my own custom
image.
Now
what I'm starting with today is
what we'd say in Scotland is heehaw.
So nothing, nada, zilch.
And we're just gonna work our way through
this custom image doc
and see if we can first and
kind of take the dev in 10 image,
make a couple of tweaks to it,
and then push that up to get that
up, and then try and deploy that onto
packet.
And assuming that works, I wanna try something
that's a little bit more adventurous,
which is to actually try and add a
new distribution.
I'm a kind of a an Arch Linux
fan, and I think it would be really
cool if I were able to deploy Arch
Linux onto a Packet machine.
So
let's first just start by
kinda covering what Packet is. So Packet is
a compute provider or a cloud provider depending
on how you wanna look at it.
And that
you can provision your own infrastructure,
you know, one machine, 10 machines, a hundred
machines,
and multiple data centers and regions around the
world so that you can deploy your application
in an elastic manner.
What's different from packet from other cloud providers
is that there is no virtualization whatsoever.
There's a lot of really cool automation going
on, but no virtualization.
And that just means that you're working with
the bare metal machine. There's no different to
having a, you know, sixteen year rack
and your own data center somewhere running your
deploying your own software to it.
So it's a really cool way of being
able to get a little bit more bang
for your buck rather than being surrounded by
noisy neighbors and virtualization and paying the small
performance hit that you would get in other
cloud providers.
So I come in here and just click
get me a new server.
I'm gonna spend something up on demand.
And these are the regions that we have
available in packet.
There's,
yeah, a good few there.
I'm gonna go with Amsterdam since that's closest
to me.
And
we will spin up a c one small.
So you can kinda see the specs here.
Now this c one small has actually got,
you know, 32 gig of RAM on it.
That small, really.
And then we have
our
images.
So for today,
let's spin up Debbie and Tan,
or at least for just now, I should
say.
And I'm just gonna call this Debbie and
Tan
demo.
We
can provide user data,
which is a,
you know, a script so that would be
executed
when the machine has been provisioned, and I
could just solve a little bit of software
there, you know, something like an app get
update and app install.
Yes.
NGINX
would give me an NGINX server.
But we're only spending up this up as
a demo, and we're gonna use the custom
image build to provide the software that we
need. The reason I wanna try and do
the custom image thing is, also, I wanna
be able to play with it and understand
how it works and and get good at
providing these sorts of images. But because the
speed of deployment will be substantially faster if
I can remove
a certain level of the provisioning step that
would have to happen after the machine had
booted.
You know, I'm a big fan of SaltStack,
and that's a great system. But if I
can have my machine already
kinda ready to run Salt on first boot
instead of me having to get it up
to up to speed, then that's gonna be
much faster for my elasticity and scale and
all these other challenges that we may have.
I'm not gonna configure the IP, and I'm
not gonna configure the SSH access either. That'll
all use my
my account's SSH key, So I should still
be able to SSH onto the machine.
Cool.
So that's gonna take
depends on the availability and there being 10.
I don't think I've actually spun that up
before. I do believe it's one of the
faster operating systems to provision. So let's just
say five minutes, and we'll maybe come back
to that and see how we're getting on.
So with regards to custom images,
I kinda skimmed this document. I mean, as
as more sensible person
may have tried this before streaming.
But I'm trying to,
I don't know, learn more in public and,
you know, make mistakes so other people can
see that too. You know, there's a lot
of value
in seeing trials and tribulations of things that
go wrong.
And
then,
you know, anyone that doesn't wanna persevere with
however long this takes me, we will condense
this down to smaller formats,
which was feedback I got on Twitter. Thank
you.
So what do I need to do? I
need to get LFS.
So do we have get LFS?
We do not.
Let's try
and install it. So
but not that work. I'm just I'm just
guessing.
What is GetLFS? Well, this, I do know.
I have used this before. So
if you've ever been in a position if
well, if you're using GET, right, you may
have been in a position where you've actually
added a really large file to your repository.
And because of how GET works, even if
you delete that file from the repository,
it still existed at a point in time,
which means the size of your repository will
always be cumulative to all the files that
you've ever added.
You know, people always add large images that
haven't been compressed for the web or they
add PDFs or, worse, they add zips, etcetera.
Now
nobody wants a large Git repository because it
means that cloning it can take a lot
of time. Obviously, there are other loopholes there.
You can do shell clones, etcetera. But,
really,
Git is not that great as storing binary
blobs.
And by binary, I mean, those are files
and images.
And custom images is definitely gonna affect that
there because the custom images we're gonna be
building today, I'm assuming they're targets.
So
what LFS does is it actually creates a
really small file inside of the GET tree,
which is a pointer to an external resource.
So when I add these images to GET,
it's gonna say, hey. You have added this
image,
which lives on GitLab or GitHub over here
on this special LFS store,
and we can reference that image. And if
we ever change it, a new version will
be uploaded, the shall will be updated in
the reference. So it's kinda like a pointer
to a fail elsewhere,
but still with the same semantics and make
sure the fail hasn't changed.
So
we have this now. Perfect.
Now it wants me to grab
get a bit to image.
So let's go and see what that is.
This is on GitHub.
Packet host. Packet images.
So packet
oh, first one. Perfect.
I've had peek at this
when I was doing my research,
my very, very brief research,
But I don't think I clicked on any
of the scripts.
So
get a bit to image.
Okay. So
works out which arch
architecture,
not arch distro.
And I just specify a version of the
bintle that we wanna fetch.
And
ah, okay.
This is just a helper script that actually
downloads
the Ubuntu base ISO
or base image
from Ubuntu website.
Cool. Okay.
Yeah. We'll we'll get it if it's gonna
make my life a little bit easier today.
So let's curl.
We'll get the printer
image.
Alright. Let's make that a bit bigger.
Alright.
Next.
So it also make that executable.
Yep. That would make sense.
Packet save to image.
Let's just see what that is too.
So that's ah, okay. So this
takes a docker image charcoal
and explodes into a root fail system. Cool.
That makes sense?
Let's download it.
But you never thought you'd be sitting watching
me download some images.
Oops.
And I'm assuming we're gonna wanna make that
beautiful.
Next. See, it is easy.
Alright. So
this is
the NRD system
for
Buntu 16 o four c one small.
Okay.
A lot to unpack there.
So Linux systems have a kernel
and our and a RD, which is a
RAM disk image, which is loaded prior to
the kernel that provides,
you know, the drivers that your machine needs
for the kernel to start, like,
you know, decrypting the desk, mounting the desk,
So I guess that's gonna be quite specific
to the c one small. So I'm gonna
have to make sure I download the right
NRD
for the machine that we wanna spin up.
A kernel
and the modules
or the modules will be specific to the
c one small two. So those two, we
need to make sure we get the correct
one.
In fact, I guess they're all gonna be
specific, but not specific to the Ubuntu.
I'm not sure
why that's part of it.
But we'll grab the ones that we wanna
modify,
and we will
maybe try and break it afterwards.
Let's get it working first. So
those were branches.
See, this is packet host, packet images raw,
and then this is a branch name.
So
if I
confirm that yeah.
Wrong scroll.
Oh, yeah. There we go. Cool. Now it
looks like the generic ones as well. Not
through me.
That mean 10.
How much you do that? It's been up
here. Oh, my machine's ready, so that's good.
Yeah. C one small. So I stick with
C 1 smalls.
And we have
two different timestamped ones.
So this one is the latter.
So
let's download
these.
So
I don't think it told me to download
an image. Yeah. Let's just get the kernel.
Mine doesn't have a Docker file.
Yeah. It'll be fine.
Let's download the NRD.
Can I just
there we go?
Save.
And the kernel.
And the modules.
It's not really confirmed that people can even
hear or see me. Let's just do that.
Oh, we have comments too.
Alright. Yeah.
So
a smarter person who is streaming would have
let me just switch back to myself for
a moment.
A smart person that would be streaming would
not have this view up and shared at
the moment, but
my MacBook Pro isn't compatible with my monitor,
and I'm currently wait my external monitor, and
I'm currently waiting on Apple engineering to fix
that for me. So,
yeah, you're just gonna have to see everything
as I do it. So I will pop
back to the questions randomly.
So what is SaltStack was a question
by Steve.
So SaltStack is a provisioning system much
like a chef, Ansible, if you're familiar with
them, or Puppet.
I'm particularly fond of Salt because it has
a few traits that the other systems don't
have.
The first one, which I think is the
most important, is just the communication method. And
that salt is event driven and communicates over
zero in queue, and the communication is entirely
one way.
That means that all of your worker nodes
or so called the minions
only have to be able to speak to
the the master
node. That's it. So the the when it
comes to my networking, security, and ports,
really, really simple. As long as your minion
and worker can reach the master,
the system just works.
What happens is this salt master will post
a message onto zero m q, which will
be picked up by one or more worker
minions.
They will execute a task, and then they
will publish a message back on the queue,
which the master will pick up and say,
hey. This was done and this wasn't done,
and it's super, super fast.
That method of working is insane.
Unlike Ansible, which I believe the SSH is
the default transport, which means you have to
have all of these SSH ports open between
all of your machines, and I am a
bit of an advocate
for never having SSH on any machine in
production ever, and this is a jump boxer.
Rick
is saying he likes to see me fumble.
Thank you. Yeah. I think it's a really
good way to learn as well. I think
seeing
people make mistakes means that you don't have
to make that mistake too. Seeing something that's
polished is nice if I wanna do a
thirty minute tutorial or learning thing, but it's
nice to nice to see mistakes happen too.
And we'll just share that because that's an
awesome.
You.
Alright.
So, like, Terraform then?
No. Terraform
is for provisioning
resources
rather than operating
systems.
Although SaltStack can also do infrastructure provisioning through
something called SaltCloud,
and Ansible actually has something for doing that
too. So it gets a little bit murky
in a way that you're gonna talk about
them. So I guess the answer is yes
and no. Maybe we can do a deeper
dive into that another point.
Yeah. How did you get the question on
the screen?
So I'm using streamyard.com,
which actually has in fact, if I share
my screen again in a second, you'll see
it. But I can actually see all the
questions from the three different platforms I'm streaming
to. So I'm streaming to YouTube, Periscope slash
Twitter, and Twitch,
and it allows me just to click show.
So let me
I I know you've got the infinite void
right now, but I can click show,
and it's cool. I like it. If only
I had a second monitor so
that we don't have to look at the
end to avoid.
So let's go back to Firefox.
Right.
So I did download all those files. Right?
One theory.
We have our NRB,
our kernel, and our modules.
Nice.
Alright.
So what we're gonna build? That's a good
question.
So we're gonna do a dev in 10,000,000,
and
we will
do something relatively trivial just now. Let's just
try and see if we can get it
pre provisioned or bit strapped with NGINX.
I wanna move these g z's into that
folder.
I will make that repo public as well
and hopefully,
with more useful images. Like, right now, kind
of what I'm thinking about is
as I learn how to do this is
that we can try to provide custom images
that anyone can use for a variety of
use cases.
One of them, which seems really obvious to
me, is a, providing a Docker Swarm setup
or a Kubernetes setup or a HashiCorp Nomad
setup
to allow people to take advantage of container
technologies on top of the bare metal compute.
Right? There's a
almost like a
just
container technologies
are great because we can, you know, hook
into the kernel without the virtualization aspect. So
the bare metal just gives you that extra
bang for your buck as well.
Right.
Docs.
Just mumbling there. Right.
I don't have a Docker file.
So let's go see what this is doing
and then maybe
hack our own together.
Alright.
Cool. There are nothing that have been too
specific there other than all the app stuff,
and I'm using Debian.
So other than a few package hiccups,
I don't see any problems.
So from scratch, the special thing in Docker,
let's see if I can get that right.
It means that you want a container image
with nothing that's old to nada.
Really good well, not good. Actually, it's really
painful.
Because what a lot of people do is
because Go and Rust and all these other
compared languages have the ability to provide a
static binary with no dependencies,
If they generally copy that binary,
this and then you have an entry point,
which is just binary,
and then they ship it to production.
It's really cool. I mean, your image is
gonna be super teeny. You know, the size
of your binaries, I'm assuming a few hundred
kilobytes, maybe a few mega worst case.
The problem with that is you have absolutely
no way to debug that container.
You cannot get into that container because there's
no there's no bash. There's no there's no
new quartiles.
I'm gonna core you to us.
There's no observability into that system unless your
application itself exposes its metrics, so it can
be a black box depending on what you're
you're doing.
Now Kubernetes is trying to make this a
lot better. I think
it was pushed from the 01/19 release, but
the 01/20 release will have the concept of
a debug container or debug
yeah. It's a container. Yeah. So you can
do kubectl
debug, and it'll actually inject a sidecar into
the pod, which gives you bash and other
debugging utens so you can take advantage of
the small binary size of a scratch image.
But that's really early stuff, so let's not
focus on that.
We don't have a root effect yet. I'm
assuming
our packet safe to image is or image,
whatever that was, is gonna provide that based
on the modules and RD and the kernel.
Maintainer is an old flag.
It shouldn't be used anymore.
And the labels I'm gonna assume these aren't
particularly important, but on the all chance that
the
packet subsystems are gonna use them, then we
will call this
I don't have a space on it, so
let's just go for that.
I will be the vendor. Sure. MIT is
the only license.
Yeah, I'm not gonna bother changing the build
date. I don't think that's gonna be important.
Although, I'm gonna do it myself. So fuck.
Can you believe it's August already?
Oh, wait.
Oh, '6.
Alright.
But they'll be in front end noninteractive.
Yep. I prefer that syntax.
We're doing an update, which I would always
recommend. You wanna keep your thing that's secure.
You wanna make sure you're always getting security
patches.
We're doing the upgrade. Nice. And then we're
doing an install.
And we have
bash past completion.
Alright.
That's weird.
I assume that's
an artifact of copy and paste, but there's
definitely no need to run the update twice.
Oh, let's just remove that. And then that's
installing kernel index.
Cool.
And the locales here, that is, you know,
pretty standard
on the bootstrapping stuff.
And then it's doing a clean.
And because these are all multiple layers, where
image is still gonna be relatively large, but
then I don't know what save to image
is doing.
So maybe it flattens it,
but there's a good chance this is
a little bit redundant. But there's also a
better chance I'm wrong.
So let's test this.
This is Docker. Right?
But, really, I can test if this works
by changing it from scratch to be Debbie
and 10 and doing a build. And if
any of it fails, it's gonna be because
the package names are different from the Bundu
to Debian,
and we can fix that.
So let's
go to Debian.
I think
what we want is that.
Do we have a 10? We do. Nice.
So let's
do a build.
Third directory,
docker
image build, and let's call us deviant ten
engine x
and go.
And start docker.
I'll just take a moment. So let's jump
back over here, see if we have any
more questions.
StreamYard,
love. Awesome.
And some annual stuff. Alright. Cool. Nothing I
need to get involved with yet. So
we spun up the server.
It didn't take very long. In fact, before
I even got through kind of my preamble
about what we're doing, it was kinda ready,
which is nice.
Docker has started, so let's actually
so
we can use this Mac keyboard.
Let's run that Docker build again and then
spin up a new tab and SSH
onto this machine
and tap the YubiKey. Knock
the YubiKey.
Alright.
I'm on a bare metal Debian 10.
It's in cloud supercomputer.
But it could get a RAM and it's
a small
that's to me, it's just phenomenal.
It's a solid connect. This is kinda what
we're gonna try and,
you know, probably like a golden image or
it's not gonna go then, where we have
Internet prebaked so that we can skip a
few minutes.
Obviously, it's a few seconds because we're not
doing anything
grand or elaborate yet.
And assuming
system being may have started that.
Yep.
Local host.
Nice.
So
this is what we wanna accomplish with our
custom image.
Let's close that.
Oh, we're already having the errors.
Okay.
So
what is
BIOS dev name on Debian?
What I'll do is so that we don't
have to watch me change 54 package names
potentially
is
I will spin this box back up first.
I'll try and fix a few of them.
And if it's just getting too cumbersome,
I will retreat when using Debian 10,
or we can always go look in the
GitHub repository for the Debian 10 Docker file,
which could work.
All those issues have been through.
So BIOS.
That then.
BIOS.
Let's try and just redirect that a little
bit. Starts with BIOS.
Alright. And don't by asking
them.
No.
Susie.
Susie
has it. The printer has it.
Let's
see.
This person seems to know what they're talking
about.
And it's a Cloudflare site.
We will wait.
Wonder if it just exists.
Oh,
or not.
Right. That plan's gonna be shit already.
So
let's just try and cut that out first.
See how many of these we're dealing with
and then
make an executive decision.
Should have prepared some jokes.
Open. That means it's installing things. Although it
says reading package list. So
Oh, come on.
One minute. I may have installed a package
yet.
Alright. Let's go and see
if we can find a Dockerfile
for one of these dev intense
before I start reinventing the wheel.
What would that mean if three of them
don't have a Dockerfile?
I guess,
I've been to
Scroll.
Oh,
same.
You will do.
So that has a Docker file.
Maybe the Debian images aren't
built with a Dockerfile,
and instead everything
happens in
the image tar g z.
Maybe this comes down to the way
those images are provided because
we
take a look at that helper script.
What
What happened there?
Run the c did not terminate successfully,
unable to locate a bunch of packages.
Yeah. So we'll probably just use a bin
two and tweak it rather than dev intent,
which means we can put that back in.
Let's run
the Bin two.
I think I got this from a sixteen
o four repository.
Just
call it the right name.
Okay. Let's leave that running. So
this does pull
an actual base image rather than, like, an
ISO installer, which I thought was cool when
I seen that at the start.
I wonder if the reason the Debian one
doesn't exist
is because they take a different approach to
the bootstrapper installation stage. I mean, this is
the base system that I'm just tweaking with
some app get updates and installs,
whereas the Debian one is probably an actual
installer
that has to
be run somewhere. I'm not sure. I will
find out,
but
not gonna focus on that now. So we're
less than a minute, and I can see
packages being installed.
That's looking a bit better.
But it does mean does mean
the images I downloaded are currently incorrect.
So
16O4C1Small.
I wonder why that one's not gonna change
that.
Which
one's the latest?
63.
Alright. That'll do. So
same as last time, let's download
the artifacts.
And it's
kernel
modules.
I don't really like talking to myself.
Should have someone come on and join me.
Right.
So give them a moment to download. Give
this docker image a moment. I mean, I'm
expecting this to work. This is the docker
file that we grabbed from the repository. If
that fails, I'd be confused.
So I don't expect that to fail, but
I also have no idea how long it's
gonna take.
Let's take a quick peek at it again.
It's not a lot. Management is decent enough.
So let's just see.
What can we do just now?
Check
questions.
Someone asked me cool questions.
Who has 20 servers?
Did I did I miss something?
Rick says, I installed Ansible.
I've got my home LAN 20 ish. So
you got 20 servers in your home LAN?
I hope they're all Pais and not actual
servers. Where would you put them?
Yes.
So you're saying I hope salt or some
derivative in the future when it's more mature
will give me a viable alternative.
Yeah. Salt is old.
I think I started using salt in twenty
fifteen,
twenty fourteen.
It's been around a few years longer than
that.
And while I would say it's mature, it
also moves that project really fast. Like, there's
a lot of breaking changes, so you really
gotta kinda keep up with that one.
Alright. Let's just share our screen again.
And what can we do? Let's go back
to our documentation.
So assuming
we test the Dockerfile, which they don't even
want us to do, but, you know, I'm
gonna do it anyway.
We can begin to build a custom image.
So I am welcome, thank you, to add
or remove packages as I see fit. And
in this example,
we have added an additional additional run command
to prove that our example
worked.
Okay.
So this
downloads the image.
So we still need to do that. Right?
We've not done that yet.
So
let's it takes two parameter three parameters.
Ah,
cool.
It ran.
So let's
tweak our image first then. Oh, no. We
can't because we still need root,
and we won't scratch. Okay.
Now we're back to where we should be.
Let's add on the package that we want.
I want.
We'll just
before
I invalidate the cache, let's make sure
those are all pretty quick steps. That is
not gonna take long, so I don't mind
invalidating the cache to here. What I could
do is jump down here and add it
here, which would keep the cache complete, and
it would only run my instruction.
But
because of that clean step,
I would have to do the app update
again,
which is, you know,
nobody cares, but
there's just no point. And I can just
add it there and sacrifice a few seconds
either way for that to run. I I
probably spent more time talking about such a
trivial situation than I have, Then it would
have been just to run it. So we're
gonna add in the next
system d well,
as we've seen on the live machine,
system d enabled and started that service for
us. So
that's a nice thing about this. Even if
that runs in a Docker container there,
there wouldn't be system d. But
because it's gonna end up on a real
machine,
hopefully, it just works.
Okay.
So
we're here.
Call our get a bit to image. Paste
those arguments we copied. So it's 16 o
four.
The current architecture
and the dot is, I'm assuming,
where to download it to.
I don't have GPG.
Well, we can fix that.
Maybe. Yeah. There we go.
So I'm assuming
again, I'm sure we could pop open that.
Let's get a bit to a mini script.
It's just gonna verify
the signature on the download,
make sure it's not been
hijacked by
the serious hackers.
I'm not doubting whether nefarious is a word.
And how streaming does funny things to your
head?
Kinda like the word friend. Have you ever
read it and typed it so many times
that it doesn't have any meaning anymore? I
did that yesterday.
Random segue.
I think that with most words with I
in it, the more you type it and
read it, it just kinda loses all meaning.
Doesn't look real.
There you go. Wonderful news while I wait.
So
let's try again.
Launch d. I assume that's a Mac thing.
It wouldn't bother me so much if everyone's
so slow.
I'm getting this whole Mac thing. I am
an on
pretty much every other machine and just type
in Pac Manor. Yeah.
It's just super fast.
Alright. So it fetched the keys.
These were not on the requirements list.
Alright.
So
let's go here.
Chat two five six.
Let's just take that. No.
I
thought it changed my search. Right? Okay.
So
someone has asked this before.
And the package we need,
core utilities.
I should've run that.
Okay.
Let's try
one more time.
Cool.
So what did we get?
We got
a bunch of base 16 o four based
Tarzip,
and it has created
a SIM link
called RootFS.
Cool.
Let's move
the SIM link and the image. Let's move
the shares in case It does enter verification
into our debian directory,
which means this is now satisfied.
Cool.
Close all that down.
Maybe.
I do.
Alright. We're good.
Yeah. Next.
We will get there.
Now we can build
our image.
Oh, let's do it's been to Internet and
go oh, wrong directory.
Nice. Let's give that a minute. So once
that finishes building,
we're gonna save the image
as a tar and then use
our packet to image
to do something.
And so it seems to be just reading
on the tar and giving us a different
tar.
So let's just
see if we can work this out.
So what does it do?
So it needs
that's a weird way to check for g
binaries,
but I guess it works.
See?
Does
that work in a Mac?
Sure does.
So we need tar, j q, and make
temp.
I'm pretty positive I have them anyway.
Make temp is a great command, actually.
I have it aliased kind of to TMP,
which is a magic function.
See these end to the main tab. I
do that whenever I wanna remove my bash
history
from, like, a livestream or something because
my bash history
is
per directory.
K. Nice.
Okay.
What does it do next?
So
it
is but it goes yeah. So the docker
image format works.
And that if I were to manually extract
this after we do the docker save, if
I were to manually extract that, we would
actually get then a different
kind of whatever it's just directories over different
tarzets for each layer,
which can then be exploded and mounted as
an overlay.
So what does overlay mean? I think we've
got a few minutes, so I'm just gonna
use my bad failures.
Let's do it. Make one forget I forget
the commands here.
What we have is two directories.
Alright. Potential fails.
Main main fail. Two directories each of us
want to fail. Now what an overlay would
allow me to do
is
the match t overlay,
one, two, three.
Nope.
Maybe that's a matching, actually.
Oh, no. I did
try.
Let's do a run r m I p
three
dash.
The max angle could just be I forgot
the command. But before I look it up,
we will test. So make one, two, three,
touch one one, two two,
overlay,
One, two, three.
I have root.
Alright. That's
overlay
Linux.
Dash t overlay.
Okay.
So the options are lower there, upper down,
work there.
Anyway, it makes sense when you see it.
How are supposed to remember that crap? Let's
try it on the Mac first then. So
we're back to here.
Our loader
is
current directory one.
I haven't started this now.
Working directory, I don't think it's important,
and I've narrowed it to three.
Alright. We will try one more time in
the container
and done with this demo.
That's too adventurous.
I don't know I made that two commands.
Okay.
Yeah. I'm right. Alright.
Yeah.
Let's try
break the last button.
Last thing. Promise.
Invalid argument.
Screw it.
What would happen
is you'd be able to type l s
three, and I would actually see files one
and two because it would overlay them together
and merge these into the mesh. So you
get a single unified view of multiple directories.
It's actually a really cool feature when you
remember how it works.
Cool. Image built.
Okay. Next.
So yeah. That's what it was. So when
you explore the target from a Docker image,
you get all those layers as their own
target fails, I think it is, which can
then each be extracted down to the home
directory.
And what Docker does is provide overlay
of all of those directories for a single
unified view.
And the working directory is for the the
copy and write stuff, but we can cover
that in our station.
So this extracts all of those images.
And
just creates a new image.
That's it. So it's just
it's just getting all the layers, merge them
together, and create a single image. Right? Like,
nothing fancy.
Cool. So
let's quickly pop over.
Alright. Cool.
If you have questions on that image stuff,
let me know.
So let's save
our image.
So we called it Aventure
NGINX,
and I would just leave that as the
exact same.
I don't think it should take too long.
Give me a moment.
And then what we wanna do is run
our packet saved image passing in
through standard and
that tar and then
the exploded version
to image dot tar dot g t.
Then what do we do? Then
we
can see all that stuff,
and then we commit it to get and
push it. Okay.
So what do we wanna do?
Let's bring in that packet script first.
So we're gonna run packet to the image
standard in
as
that,
and we'll
call this packet. We're gonna do
and it does g zipped it, so let's
do that.
Not Mac friendly.
Let's fix that. I'm not Mac friendly either.
That's okay.
So it doesn't like
this flag,
which I don't believe
is important.
I removed you.
Two of them. Right.
Oh, does that expect us to run on
the notes? Why is it
why is it creating devices?
Houston, we've had a problem.
Okay.
What can we do?
Let's cheat.
So
we're now getting into I have no idea
what I'm kidding. Maybe I wanna be doing,
but I'm gonna try and get around this
maxing
by
using a container.
Actually, it's been through a 16 o four
since that's what we have. Yes. Everything so
far. We're gonna note in
this directory to code and set the working
directory to code.
And
I wanna run bash.
And I need to tell it to run
a container.
We'll try and run a packet save to
image thing from here.
See what happens.
So
why has that
failed?
Let's just echo that command.
Looks fine.
Oh, wait. It can't
find
dolly. I wish it must have come after
all the parameters, and I definitely
know that.
Rawkode
packet images,
Debian.
It's the wrong button.
Oh, it's Mac.
Okay. I've been to
so
this
may or may not work.
And put a bit to
output.
Accurate a bit to
now I don't have all the requirements,
which is probably not gonna exist in a
vintage sex female, and I'll be pleasantly surprised
if it does.
Yay.
I feel as excited as I get, by
the way.
Working.
Doctor, you are a wonderful thing sometimes.
So,
hopefully, this won't take too long. Probably gonna
take longer than it would have if I
was on native Linux because we are going
through an annoying
clone of a fail system or sync of
the fail system. I can't remember what
Mac OS is using and Docker are using.
I just remember it being painfully slow when
working with interpreting languages with Python and PHP.
So that's me.
Take a little bit longer than I would
have expected.
Alright. Let's see what's next. So we delete
all the crud, and then we're doing the
LFS.
So
it
wants me to store we didn't create a
get attributes.
But the
oh, the fact this LFS track will create
the get attributes. So I won't have to
do that manually.
Then we push all of that.
And then what do we do? So then
to deploy our custom image,
we use a special version of the user
data
to tell it to pull it.
Cool.
And that's it.
Fingers
crossed.
So let's drop it less.
Let's
do
get LFS
track start dot.
I can just
I'm
just gonna track one mail.
Their packet
one.
Oh, let's fix that. I don't see how
to start with nothing.
Okay. So let's track that. That should create
the get attributes.
Perfect.
I'm not gonna delete stuff. I'm just gonna
add the files that I think it wanted
me to add.
I don't want no. I don't want the
shadows. The only wanted attributes
on the Dockerfile.
Yep. We've got that.
Cool.
And what do I do next?
Just image.
That I can handle.
Commit. So
let's call this feature.
Open to image with engine x.
That's the repository
that exist.
Okay.
Which is
not important.
Okay.
Yes. Remote
and origin.
We get past.
I get I get initial
branch.
That's
the thing there.
Good.
At LFS
track
Debian
packet. It's been two.
I wanna move that catch because, actually, I
don't want it to be inside of that
directory.
And then get at Debian
Yeah. Debian.
And
save the directory.
Why am I not oh, no.
Yeah. And so
I only tracked the packet one, but I
actually wanna track those
other ones. I'm just having a major fail.
Okay. Let's go in here.
Yeah.
Try there's a reason they use star dot
tarzip, but I don't want to delete all
of my tarzips.
Okay. So we're gonna track this one, this
one, this one, and this one.
I also want to add a Docker file.
And
Cool.
Do I
need to add those separately?
Hope I'm doing the right thing here.
You just don't add them even though we
got the attributes. Cool.
That will do the right thing, I'm sure.
So
and that kernel devian module devian
kernel modules
in it
and packet.
It'd be nice to me.
Commit.
Yeah. Push origin
latest.
Update rest.
Get remote at origin.
Push YubiKey.
Push
YubiKey.
Wait.
I mean,
think it's pushing. My UB keys.
Oh, there we go. Okay.
Hopefully, this is
quickish.
I was hoping I'd keep this under an
hour,
and we're close,
but we are at the hour.
Yep.
So
when this goes up,
we should
be able to refresh this.
It's not quite there yet
and deploy
like so.
Oh, I really should've shut it down.
Bye bye.
So the case doesn't matter,
but, you know, I asked for it with
a capital d. So
okay.
So Amsterdam.
See one small
custom.
Nope. That's custom pixie.
Does it matter?
Does it say
yeah. So I think I just pick Ubuntu,
but then use my own flavor.
So let's call this
Ubuntu NGINX.
Add the user data that it expects
and point
it to the correct repository.
So getthat.com.
It was in a supplementary tray.
Sugar.
How do I make that work?
There's a reason these are all branches in
a root directory. Right?
Dress.
So this is just using
code config
images.
I mean, is this a standardized
thing?
I
just click Google, get results that actually make
sense.
Let's not fit with this. Let's
wait for this to finish, create a branch,
and move the files to the root. Let's
just push it and test it,
and then I'll work out if I can
use a directory approach later.
Yeah. I never really thought of that.
Uploaded 350
meg.
Hopefully, not
lot to go.
Packet images.
Let's go into 10.
So three ninety,
and those are all pretty small.
So it shouldn't
have much more to go.
Not sure why it's larger
than four fifty so far. All the modules
are actually quite big. Alright. Okay.
Come on, computer.
So what I'm gonna do is
switch. I see.
Then to engine x.
Move
my attributes.
Let's just go and save that directory.
Put the attributes and the modules, the kernel,
and the packet
image
of a directory.
Let's get
add those files again.
And commit.
Correct.
Keep
images and rip directory.
Until I work, I have to make that
not the case.
Why does it not add the deletions?
And then the
the modules,
the the kernel,
and the.
But I have my alias. No.
I haven't got them set up yet.
Commit amend. No
edit.
Get came as I normally have the alias
configured.
And
push origin.
Those files haven't changed.
So, hopefully
alright. It's just maybe we keep pitching too
many times.
Hopefully, it doesn't upload them all again.
Okay. So it's down the ref log. It
should be smart enough to handle that.
Yep. Perfect.
And
we have our directory version here
and our Ubuntu version
here.
What?
Ah, the Dockerfail.
Is that important?
We'll find out. So
oh, but now it's on a branch.
Is that what it mean? Yeah. Let's just
use this. I'm assuming that's a commit share
for the branch.
So
let's go with that.
And
go.
It's gonna break, isn't it?
Definitely gonna break.
I've got an IP address, but then that
sets still during its own magic stuff, which
is setting up networking.
Where will my bit be?
Here.
Step eight.
So I'm I'm not entirely sure how this
is working
because
a bit
a bit 21604,
which we've chosen as a base image and
our user data as a user data, something
that happens afterwards.
So it's using the base system to do
the install,
protection the disks,
and set up the networking, and then the
clear then that stuff comes in.
Now
our image contains
an entire base system.
So I'm gonna have to find someone on
engineering and work out
what it's actually doing here
because it's not
just gonna replace the desk with my image.
Maybe it does.
I'm not sure.
But then how would it then get
the networking config and stuff in? I'm just
curious how that works.
I'm I'm gonna work I'll find out.
Oh,
I'm hoping it doesn't fail,
and I'm hoping it works.
And I will sit in silence until it
does
because that's entertaining.
My failure is much more entertaining. Let's pop
over here.
So what do we got?
Rex gonna look at StreamYard. Lorraine loves StreamYard.
Let's just show random messages. Cool.
So back to REx 20 pieces of hardware,
six real pieces of hardware,
one pie,
one net top, four self bolt mini ITX
machines,
and LXC containers and all of those.
Cool.
Uh-huh.
Let's just go back and watch the magic
thing. Oh,
no way.
Surely, it didn't work.
Doesn't look like it worked.
K. It worked.
I can't SSH onto it.
Definitely
broken.
Let's get some debug here.
SSH isn't running.
Okay.
I've never had to I've never used a
abandoned phone. You don't work. Go away.
But we should be able to get
it's not going on to the system.
Yes. I've broken it.
Serial over SSH. Yes. Give me a thanks.
Pretty sure I only have one key.
Oh,
You'll be key at
try again.
Maybe it does work then.
No. That definitely doesn't. Okay. What about the
other bad one?
Better.
Dreads.
So it's definitely broken.
Oh, well.
Not sure there's anything
else I can do.
Ah.
Well, that's not gonna work. There's no SSH
on.
Yeah. This was failing because of the key.
I'm not giving up. Okay. Got a plan.
Let's
spin up
another
oh, no. Because this SSH isn't running.
So I can't even go through the internal
IP address.
Run it.
Got it. Open to Internet bash.
And SSHD is there.
Some detail
for SSH is
there.
Why
is it not running SSH?
I mean, I'm kind of assuming right now
that I haven't just broken the entire install.
Assuming those are the defaults
and port 22.
Public key authentication.
Is there anything I can do?
So let's try again.
I can actually refuse this
pretty quick.
Would it was
it running,
or is this something else?
I got nothing.
Why does the band
console not work?
Thanks. It could come in. It's a little
safer.
Let's see.
No.
It's actually about right.
Impression.
That's a good command.
You know, like, I should know that.
Oh, you just
you just.
Alright. Let's try.
No. Okay.
So I'm
completely out of ideas.
So I'm going to shut this down.
Almost rescue OS.
I have no idea.
I don't know
what I've done.
Can I use the band now? Is that,
like,
Yeah.
Destroy.
So do we have anything in chat?
So
Rain has asked if it's possible
to see the system that it's been bringing
up.
I I don't think so. I'm not really
sure.
Would be cool. I'm not sure what my
next steps are actually right now.
So I'm gonna have to speak to someone
with more knowledge than me.
Maybe someone who built a custom image before,
get them to join me, and I think
we will try again
either tomorrow or next week. I don't know
where I went wrong. I mean, it could
just be as simple as SSH
wasn't started, but then I don't even understand.
There's a disconnect
from
the image I built with the Docker file,
you know, adding that root f s and
then tweaking it,
and how we get to that stage based
on the cloud and it specifying the repository
and the which I'm assuming is a. I
don't even know that right now. I'm assuming
that was supposed to be a,
but maybe not.
It could be there's no visibility from
the machine booting up and my image being
replaced onto it somehow. I don't I can't
see through the GUI, and maybe it could
have been, like,
maybe
if I was a bit more patient, maybe
it takes time to pull the image from
GitLab and provision it. And because I popped
over to check for questions instead of watching
the steps, I don't even I'm assuming it
completed.
I don't know if there was a way
for me to get other information.
So
rather than me trying to spin that up
again,
I will solicit some help from someone who
knows a little bit more about this than
me, and we will try this again.
So
I'm gonna leave it there.
If there's anything else that you want to
see me cover with regards to
packet,
not building custom images,
reach out to me on Twitter. Let me
know If you have questions from today's stream
that you would like answered, let me know,
and I will do my best to help.
Anyway,
thanks for watching.